I just want to know what the Bible has
to say. My whole life I've been a truth
seeker and there's been topics that I've
been taught my whole life in church
growing up that I found out when I read
God's word they weren't even true. It
always comes back to this topic of well
God burns people for eternity. Even if
it's just for one lifetime of ignorance
that's always always 100% comes up in
debates against Christianity.
>> We still want to we we want the
eternity. It's still begging the
question. The alternative is hell.
That's the issue I have. If there was a
first class, a business class, and a
coach,
>> I'm with it. I don't got to be first
class. That's fine. But the idea that
that is a like God doesn't owe you
heaven. He don't He don't need to give
you hell. Sin caused being banned from
the tree of life. So, we're all sinners.
We don't have right to the tree of life
clearly because we all die causing
death. We all know that this is we sin.
We don't have right to the tree of life
and we will die. But one day, those that
keep the commandments of God will have
right to the tree of life again. For the
wages of sin is death, but the gift of
God is eternal life through Jesus Christ
our Lord. Now ask yourself, how can the
wicked burn for eternity if they don't
have the gift of eternal life or access
to the tree of life? Ask yourself that
question. The wicked are not going to
put on immortality at the last trumpet.
They did not receive the gift of God
which is eternal life and they will not
have right to the tree of life. So how
can they burn forever and ever and ever
for the endless eternity ceaseless? They
cannot because they do not have
immortality. They do not have
everlasting life. They do not have right
to the tree of life so that they can
keep burning and burning and burning.
This is a lie from the pit of hell that
makes God look like a tyrannical monster
and it's caused countless go-hating
atheists. This is the fate of Satan.
Ezekiel 28:16 and 19. And I will destroy
thee, oh covering cherub. I will bring
forth a fire from the midst of thee. It
shall devour thee. So destroy, devour,
and I will bring thee to ashes. Satan is
going to be turned to ashes upon the
earth, and never shalt thou be anymore.
Satan is going to be destroyed.
Revelation 21:4 says, "And God shall
wipe away all tears from their eyes, and
there shall be no more death, no more
sorrow, no more crying, neither shall
there be any more pain. For the former
things have passed away, but Jesus is
not a tormentor. God is love, and I
cannot wait for him to return. Jesus is
coming soon.